[Music]
suddenly there are a lot of Democrats
running for their party's presidential
nomination there's some disagreements
between them but one thing many of them
appear to agree on is wholeheartedly
embracing the foreign policy agenda of
Bill Kristol whether it's Syria or
Venezuela or Russia there's an
opportunity for the United States to
sponsor violent conflict somewhere in
the world they support it the only
exception to this is congresswoman Tulsi
Gabbard of Hawaii she's a sincere
progressive she is a veteran and she
says she wants to keep America out of
pointless foreign wars and for that she
has been repeatedly attacked in
Washington congressman Gabbard joins us
thanks very much for coming on I know
that you have been criticized for
straying out of approved media outlets
I'm surely criticized for coming on the
show tonight I just want to reassure
Democratic voters we disagree on many
many probably most of things you are
since your progressive but one place
that I admire your courage is your
unwillingness to go along with the
foreign policy views of everyone else in
Washington and you really have been
attacked for it why do you think that is
oh look Tucker I am a soldier in the
Army National Guard I've served now for
nearly 15 years served on two
middle-east deployments and I know
personally firsthand the cost of war in
Congress now for over the last six years
I've served on the Foreign Affairs
Committee as well as the Armed Services
Committee and I have seen how
self-serving powerful politicians from
both parties have continued this foreign
policy regime change war view where they
think that we the United States should
be acting as the policemen of the world
and that we should continue to go around
and overthrowing and toppling dictators
or or countries who we don't like
costing us the American people trillions
of dollars in the process causing more
suffering in the countries where we go
and wage these wars and oh by the way
undermining our own national security as
we are seeing playing out before our
eyes and countries like North Korea yes
where Kim jong-un has clearly stated
that he is holding on to these nuclear
weapons as his only deterrent against
the United States coming in and waging a
regime change war in North Korea so
while you know I'm deeply concerned
about the fact that this summer
yesterday ended without an agreement
because we we need to see
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
it's not surprising because of this
policy this regime change war policy
that again leaders and both parties in
the foreign policy establishment here in
Washington have perpetuated over and
over and over again what's so
interesting is that that world view the
regime change world view I mean if it
worked at one time I thought it sounded
late made sense but we've had almost 20
years of it and it demonstrably hasn't
worked when there's really no debate
about how badly it's gone why would
people still support that that's a great
question you know it's if you look at
the the military industrial complex that
benefits off of these continued regime
change wars you look at those in
Washington who's invested their entire
careers built on continuing to wage
these wars and the most unfortunate
thing is they sell them and to the guise
of humanitarianism to the American
people who want to be able to do good
things who want to be able to help
people who are suffering but not
pointing out the fact and not facing the
truth that in each of these different
examples of regime change led by the
United States it has resulted and far
more suffering for the people who
they're supposedly trying to help now
there's a lot of different motives for
this you can look at corporate greed you
can look at who actually benefits
financially yes from these wars if you
want to see why they're continuing and
why it perpetuates again by self-serving
powerful politicians and leaders in both
parties has anyone know you've been
attacked quite a bit I'm not gonna make
you relive it including by some people I
know who which should know better to be
honest with you but nobody has engaged
you in the argument you just made and so
they've dismissed you is sucking up to
this dictator you're a bad person is
basically what they're saying has
anybody actually debated you on the
points that you're making
no no constantly I see again people from
both parties instead resorting to
name-calling or superficial attacks
because they refuse to engage on the
substance of
this argument about why they continue to
push for and try to wage these
regime-change wars ignoring the
disastrous consequences on the people in
those countries and the American people
the reality is these these wars are
costing us the taxpayers trillions of
dollars dollars that should be here that
should remain in our pockets are
invested in things like rebuilding our
crumbling infrastructure invested in the
needs of our people I just want to say
again just to be totally clear we
disagree on many things but I admire
your bravery for saying that out loud
and you were always welcome on the show
I appreciate your company very much
appreciate it